I noticed last night or I was told I
didn't see it but I heard everybody
stood for the national anthem and that
shows respect for a country or flag and
for the national anthem so you know I'm
very happy I heard that and they should
stand you have to stand it's our
national anthem you have to stand all
right that was the president earlier
today praising the players and the fans
who stood during last night's game that
was in Green Bay joining us now from the
Trump Organization the son of the
president Eric Trump good to see you
first interview since the baby the baby
we're excited excited right a little
Luke get any tired late nights late
nights nights
mom was I'm almost feeling some late
nights but she says she's doing great
yeah good for you I thought this was
important for the country I don't know
what's gonna happen this weekend I know
fans are still mad even at the locking
of arms because they think it's still a
type of protest but if we if we're not
gonna take a stand here and decide as a
country that there's there's certain
things that will unify us our anthem our
flag and a remembrance of all those that
fought bled and died on fighting for
that flag under that flag thoughts I
don't mind locking the arms I don't mind
lock the arms at all I mind kneeling and
my father Minds kneeling and you know
it's one thing I've always said well my
father he'll fight for this country and
this was another great example of him
fighting for this country it's not just
fighting for lower taxes it's not just
fighting for you know better healthcare
and fighting to have the best military I
mean he's fighting for something that
means a tremendous amount to this nation
to the people of this nation that's the
American flag and that's patriotism and
there's plenty of time for protest
alright but just keep that one minute
time that it takes to sing the national
anthem keep its sacred there's another
23 hours and 59 minutes in a day keep
that minute sacred and it's really great
to see so many teams coming around to
this if we're in so many different ways
it's a win and I think it was also a
defining moment and in other ways great
to pay for the country to have and I
think that was the missing ingredient
for this was the number of men that
fought under that flag and what it meant
to them and how much they've given to
all of us right
and we'll see what happens this weekend
I I would hope this is the end of it and
you know what the American flag stands
for everything that's great about this
country right now every country has
atrocities every country has little
problems but America we are so fortunate
as people I mean I've traveled all
around the world as you have and you've
seen where real countries have got it
wrong I mean should turn on the TV look
what's happening in North Korea look at
so many countries where people are you
know starving starving oppressed
we certainly have with certain problems
in this country but we are so blessed on
a relative basis and you know we should
stand and we should celebrate that and
then you know when that's over we can
debate our differences and that's
healthy but you know it's it's I'm proud
of him taking a stand and I'm proud of
him fighting for that flag I don't think
your father is ever going to be managed
in the sense that he's ever gonna make
decisions based on anything other than
what his heart and gut tells him and I
don't I think that's a missing
ingredient where people don't know about
your father because he's not a
politician it's not a politician I mean
right I mean every time you see
politician out there they you know they
they choose every single word perfectly
they study these little catch phrases
that can apply to any person
individually and never never get them
and my product goes out there and he
speaks from the heart and that's why he
was ultimately elected I mean people are
sick and tired of the nonsense sound
bites people are sick and tired of
political correctness and quite frankly
people you know and that's why
government never got anything done I
want to play video of an officer an
indie Indianapolis officer police
officer and he was on a stretcher and he
had he was in the motorcade of the
president when they were leaving and
before the president he had heard about
the accident before he goes wheels up he
made at a point of talking to this man
he's truly one of the most charismatic
compassionate people you'll ever see and
the media will never paint him that way
but it's the father I know actually
tweeted that article before because I
thought it was beautiful and you saw the
officer and he's lying on the back and
he has the neck brace and he has a phone
somebody's holding a phone to his ear
and you know my father's thanking him
for a service you know telling him to
you know to recover quickly to heal up
quickly and it's the father I know it's
a man I know him to be he's got a
tremendously big heart the Indianapolis
metro police they sent out a tweet
Thank You @potus for delaying wheels up
to speak with an injured officer injured
officer Turner
he has never walked by a police officer
even even prior to his life in
government where he hasn't said thank
you my father is deeply deeply patriotic
he cares about law enforcement you Saul
down the campaign trail and I think you
see it every single day and you
certainly saw it yesterday when when he
did that what do you I'm watching Milani
Milani is on her way to go help people
in Texas after hurricane Harvey walks
out of the White House she and the the
media is so shallow they're fixated on
her shoes Malati it donates dr. Seuss
books which I assume you're probably
gonna be reading to Luke when he's a
little bit older maybe sooner and the
others like Barry the librarian who
writes such a nasty note to Melania and
I don't remember your sisters been a
target of this kellyanne's been a target
of this everybody everybody that is
close to the president seems to be
targeted but Melania now in particular
seems to be singled out it she's amazing
I just I'm listening I'm a better
interview door she is wrong she's smart
she cares
she's been an unbelievable force in this
whole thing I mean when would a simple
thank you be enough and go a long way I
mean I read that letter and I thought it
was smug I thought it was arrogant I
mean here was the first lady of the USA
you know my father's platform has been
education he thinks it's a total
embarrassment that is a country that
we've been rated number 30th in the
world in terms of education and we won
and spend the money per pupil no
question about it
and and he is hell-bent on fixing that
problem believe me I mean it's literally
it was always one of the first points he
ever you know he made in every single
campaign speech he talks about it all
the time so here money goes out and
promotes national read a book day right
I mean something beautiful something
innocent they donate dr. Seuss books to
a bunch of schools and in every state
and she gets criticized by a librarian I
mean that that's the divisive miss of
the world that we live in how about a
simple thank you thank you for the books
and by the way even if they couldn't
utilize them you know we have many
people who you know are less fortunate
and we'll make sure that they end up in
wonderful hands and thank you for taking
this initiative because education of our
youth is really important this is a
librarian
hop on pop and it has real eggs in him
and it has to be a smug nasty response
and
it's unfortunate and it's a shame and
she is an amazing amazing woman so
congratulations
you know maybe they can give the copies
of the books to you and Laura so you
guys can ruin you or gonna ngratulations
on the baby-making awesome news for both
of you thank you